[Music]
this is going to be a hard one to figure
out but i want you guys to try that
we'll figure it out then you get the
first crack okay let's go the cambodian
prime minister has decided to change his
legal date of birth why would he do that
holy [ __ ]
huh because he wants to be younger
so he could hit up the young shorties
i think because there's probably an age
limit
and before he gets out of his power he
wants to change it so he can be damn
really good that's the most serious as
good as mine but that's a good that's a
good idea i'm gonna add a little bit a
little bit more of a um he wants to date
underage cambodian girl i mean this
guy's been in power since 1985. well the
answer lies in zoolander because he was
in it yeah
that's a malaysian prime minister
he's been a president since 1985. so
there's no he's been prime minister
since 1985. prime minister is basically
president yeah well he he pulled some
little funny stuff and like has been in
power ever since that's that's a very
long reign who else has a guess why do
you think he'd want to change his
birthday because he wants to identify as
young
he wants to be a sagittarius or
something i thought i thought he wanted
to do it to like have his birthday land
on a holiday or something so you could
like that's close that's so that's the
closest thing so far what yeah so i
think that one's more productive wait he
didn't change his birthday to christmas
right no but he did change it so that i
mean he's 71 but uh the date change
would make him 69. and that's why he's
not doing it for like yeah
he's a hilarious guy
who wants to go two years younger yeah
why would you do that to yourself his
legal birthday from april 4 1951 to
august 5 1952.
to be on a holiday like a cambodian new
year or something it's really close you
guys could probably guess if you did if
you thought one more make it more asian
and you'll get it [ __ ] not lunar you
know here so you could be the year of
the world so he could have he could be
the zodiac animal he wants yes oh
what is it
doesn't he have a [ __ ] country he
needs to run
no birthday first
i mean look i know we're at war but i
want this party really really bad i
always wanted this dragon tattoo
since i was born in the year of the goat
i could never get the bear he was a goat
tattoo so lame for a prime minister
it's the chinese zodiac what so what's
the animal yeah what's the cool animal
watch yourself rat
i freak out i forgot it's gotta be like
the tiger or the dragon i like how this
was changing his birthday that's some
boss moves dude for the longest time i
felt like i identified more of the year
of the tiger
so like oh yeah so he wants to be under
year of the tiger instead of you're the
cow
cows aren't cool you imagine getting a
cow tattoo like check out my cow hey
cows are big though i saw one at the
fair i was like damn this [ __ ]
big
cows are big
did you pay a dollar to see the world's
biggest cow you know it's all hidden in
a tent no but i walked up on when i was
like like [ __ ] this thing like you touch
it it's just like a brick wall you're
just like holy [ __ ] if you paid a dollar
to see the world's biggest cow you walk
in and you're like where is it and
they're like you're in
he just it into his ass funny this fool
is like he's like a white girl from uc
santa barbara dude like you know how
they're like hella into horoscopes and
[ __ ] so this fool's like going through
our life and he goes you know
people always said that i have traits
like a tiger and then every time he does
something goes oh you know you're the
tiger so it's like you know people like
oh yeah i'm a pisces you know i just
gonna be doing my pisces thing you know
that's why so that's probably what it is
like he always felt that that was his
thing and then so now he gets to really
identify with his he saw american
politics it was like i can do that how
many like different animals are there 12
12 12. i don't even know i don't even
know it's like rat
no 12 years wait wait let him name him
all let him name him oh it's not because
of the monster go ahead go ahead name
every one of them
we're gonna name every zodiac animal all
right rooster yeah all right rooster
tiger
uh
if you get at least five honorary asian
cow okay uh and you can say chicken
just fill the chart with whatever all
right rooster
cow
tiger
um
i feel like there's like a mermaid okay
yeah all right keep going maybe a coin
fish or something uh
yeah there's a fish you seriously said
you said mermaids
mermaids even asian yeah
ariel was white what
she's a redhead a snake is that a snake
okay minotaur
i'm like
pegasus oh pegasus yeah is there a bear
yeah bear did i say monkey already
monkey
eight eight is that it oh there's twelve
four more four more asian animals
bruce lee
um
let's see you're of the spare rings like
a like an ant or something like that and
yep a pig pig oh they did have a pig
um two more two more
now i can't think of animals uh i said
bear already right think of mythical
creatures unicorn unicorn all right
eleven and my little pony and the
twelfth and the most important elephant
elephant elephant hey dude you got them
all right this was so asian good job man
you're asian very asian dude i think i
got half of them wrong dude
there's no mermaid there's no fish you
sure there's no ant there's no ants
no bears no by gala
i think that's a regular horoscope
you're the fetus no do you guys actually
know all right i'm gonna try it i'm
gonna go
get
dragonite
all right dragon mouse cow
pig
okay dragon mouse cow pig
snake
monkey
um
rooster
um ant yeah we're back to ants [ __ ] i
only got seven
cocoons i said cow it's supposed to be
an oxen oh it's a og
let me give you guys another cambo quiz
since we're talking about cambodia bring
it why is it that a lot of cambodians
have two birthdays
because during the war
they [ __ ] came here and they don't
have papers they don't even know none of
that [ __ ] so that's why they had to make
it up that does happen but the
cambodians still in cambodia why do some
of them have two birthdays is it like
the lunar calendar and then the regular
calendar something happened in the 70s
that gave everybody two birthdays what
oh fight club they they freaking
destroyed all the credit towers
everybody's information was gone so i
had to re-register their birthday how
did i not know fight club took place in
70s cambodia movies have the answers to
everything
no it's because the um i might be saying
this wrong the khmer rouge regime from
1975 to 1979 they wiped all the records
oh
fight club
so they just had to make another one so
everybody's birthdays got [ __ ] up that
was a genocide right on their own people
would be kind of cool to choose your own
birthday what would your birthday be i
kind of like my birthday when's your
birthday it's september 19th but i like
even numbers so i probably would have
done the 20th okay that's dead shout out
my mom has two birthdays cause she uh
she emigrated here from vietnam and they
re-registered their birthdays to
whatever they wanted for whatever reason
so your mom was like i like this date
better yeah yeah really she just chose
it right i think a lot of asian
immigrants or
parents that came over here they picked
their own birthdays because they'd be
registered i think my mother-in-law has
the same thing too she's from el
salvador and her her birthday shaved
some years
off my mom was always like it's almost
my birthday not my real one though i was
like okay imagine if you think you're
doing some kind of cool hack by like
making yourself younger on paper but for
the rest of your life people just go you
look old
shout outs like cambodian pm you're 17.
isn't that crazy just a few generations
ago
our like
record keeping wasn't actually that good
and it's that easy to just like not know
what your real birthday is but now
everything is like i know a million
checks and balances you know now your
birthday's on the blockchain baby yeah
you ever think how crazy it is like
everybody has social security number
yeah you ever think that if you have a
baby and don't take it to the hospital
we have a baby in your house that baby
could have zero social security number
and they wouldn't exist that's like
george washington he didn't have a
social security number george washington
he didn't have a social security number
he had wooden teeth didn't he yeah
and fake hair she was also on the dollar
bill
got lice too
nasty needs head shoulders yeah so it's
actually pretty common for people in
comedy have two birthdays and then
choose one or the other wow because the
prime minister hasn't done it he's never
got around to it until he just picked a
new one he's just gonna get in with the
program so do they celebrate both
birthdays that sounds like fun that's
why i think cambodians like to party all
the time i'm saying probably popping out
there there's like so many birthdays are
lit over there but yeah that guy um the
prime minister he the reason why he's
been empowered to 85 is because once
they um they took power they
pretty much eliminated all the other
opposition so there's no one to run
against i was going to make a joke about
that but then it turned out to be true
you just said it so it's good no let's
hear the joke still no no i just said
he's not going to start with that
okay who's there
who's there a minister
[Music]
you